I'm so excited to meet you in person.
I am so excited, honestly.
And Drew, your kitchen is gorgeous.
The Moody Foody likes it, I'm so happy.
(applause)
Drew, I love it.
You don't understand what a stamp of approval that is.
The Moody Foody is so perfect.
When and where did you come up with that name?
I thought, I feel like when it comes to food,
everyone always asks, "What are you in the mood for?"
And it's like, everyone's always asking like,
"Do you want Thai, Chinese, Mexican food?
What are you in the mood for?"
And I thought, moody, foodie, I think is perfect.
Oh, like it's a mood as well, 'cause it's true,
what are you in the mood for?
Oh.
And I feel like with food, it's like, not only is the food
delicious, but you set the mood, put the right song on,
light some candles and you have this delicious dish.
It's all about the mood.
Well, I'm so excited because the dish that you wanted
to bring, you picked literally one of my favorite
all-time dishes of my life that I had been eating
since I was a child, one of my number one favorite foods
in the world, chilaquiles.
So, if there's anyone I want to learn this from, it's you.
Will you please teach all of us?
I would love to teach you all
how to make chilaquiles.
I mean, first of all, it's a very Instagramable dish.
It's a beautiful looking dish, and it tastes amazing.
So, let's start off.
I think the first step, especially if you're like,
starting to cook, which I know that you cook a lot,
but for anyone starting to cook at home.
I always feel like I'm starting.
It doesn't matter.
So do I, I'm not culinarily trained like, at all.
Oh God.
I'm just a home cook.
Really?
I'm shocked 'cause you just, and also,
you know what you have is patience and grace,
two things I completely lack.
So, okay, how do we start?
We're going with the onion?
Well, first of all, I like to start off with,
I'd like to throw a towel around my shoulder
so it looks like I know what I'm doing.
I feel like everyone that does this,
you just lean over the counter, you have a towel
and everyone's like, "That's a cook."
Okay, so we roast onions and tomatoes on a sheet pan,
is that how you prepare it?
Yeah, you can do it on a sheet pan, a cast iron,
kind of whatever you have.
You just char up the tomatoes and the onions and the garlic,
which, in Mexican cooking it's very common to see this,
adds so much flavor to it.
And then we have right here, some (speaks Spanish)
which is very common again in Mexican cooking,
some Mexican oregano, salt and pepper,
and we just toss that all in,
and we've boiled these peppers down a little bit,
so they're nice and soft.
And the good thing about these is it's,
what's your spice tolerance, Drew?
High, I love spice.
Prefect, 'cause we have plenty of the little ones.
The little ones are very spicy, but the good thing is
in Mexican cooking we use a lot of chilies,
but they're not all super spicy, they just add
a lot of flavor.
And the seeds will also determine, how much seedage,
more spicy.
If you don't really want to be super spicy,
but you like the flavor, just take out the seeds
and you're good to go.
Perfect.
So we pop this in and then we just
pulse it on low.
(blenders whirring)
There we go.
Now, right here, we're just gonna add some broth,
and just like, eyeball it.
(whirring continues)
And if it looks saucy enough.
I think it looks perfect.
There's three spouts and I didn't get one right!
I think a little bit went into the blender.
A little bit went into the blender, and all of it went
everywhere else.
Yeah, so then, basically I'm just gonna
want to add the sauce onto the pan and cook it down
just a little bit.
And then, this is called epazote, and this herb is amazing.
If you can find it at Mexican grocery store,
it's like, citrusy, it's very pungent,
peppery and a little minty.
It's phenomenal.
So if you can find a epazote, it's fantastic.
And with this, it's pretty simple, it's pretty pungent,
so I just like to add a few leaves right here,
keep it on the stem and then you just kind of like,
slap it in the pan.
And then at the end we're just gonna remove it.
And then once the sauce is down, then what do we do?
We're just gonna take this out.
I'm just gonna use this little fork right here to like,
take this out.
And then you kind of like, discard that.
I don't want to just toss this.
I'm gonna put that in my favorite.
(crowd chuckles)
And then you grab these beautiful things,
and these are called totopos.
They're just tortilla chips.
But in Mexico they call them totopos.
When you see them like this, you're like,
"Oh, so much love went into that."
Oh absolutely.
So homemade.
Oh, I like to toss them into the sauce,
but I mean, you do your thing.
Oh, no, wait, you're teaching me, tell me what to do.
See, I'm not gonna do it right,
you're gonna teach me.
So then you just cover these up.
And like I said earlier, it's a very Instagramable dish.
Now that I've coated it all, do I plate?
Yes.
And so, I just like to spoon this in.
Kinda let it look organic, but also with a lot of intention.
And then we're gonna have this fun, chipotle, assembly line
situation, so we wipe this down and then,
Crema?
Yeah, crema.
And this is also like, you can make this super vegan if,
if you're a vegan, this dish can be completely veganized,
and I like to add the crema just 'cause of that satisfying.
Oh, we went very different methods.
What'd you do?
I like it.
Very like, Jackson Pollock.
I went in a hypnotic circle, you went ziggidy zaggidy.
Okay, what's next?
Drew, you're an artist.
Which layer next?
I like to add the, I like to add the onion.
Okay, good.
I'm asking you because I really do want to follow you,
even if I do it a little differently, like,
I know your steps are gonna be better than my methodologies.
Okay, next?
I like to add the, the egg on top and just plop that on,
like, right there.
I mean, how beautiful are these eggs, by the way?
I know, the yolk is gorgeous.
They're so pretty.
(applause)
Now I like to add the cheese, and then just like,
crumble it on here.
And what I like about the crema and the cheese is it,
if you like it spicy, it's just like, that nice little
cooling effect that you get.
And then after that, I like to top it off with just
a little bit of cilantro and I don't like to chop it,
I just like to throw it on there.
And then you just toss it with a lime.
I'm a huge fan of lime on like, every food.
(applause)
That looks beautiful.
What do you think?
I think that's beautiful, I love it.
You're amazing.
(applause continues)
It has been a dream of mine to work with you.
Please, please, please, can we do this again?
Yes, I would love that.
I would love that so much.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
Fabrizio Villalpando, also known as the Moody Foody.
Check out his videos if you're not one of the 70 million
people already watching.
For this recipe, go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
My very first chilaquiles, with you, cheers.
Cheers.
Thank you so much.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)